eu queria propor aqui pra vocês um
exercício que a gente fizesse agora o
exercício rápido abençoe nou programa
infantil que vocês assistiram que vocês
gostavam aquele programa que quando
vocês assistimos e se sentiam bem
assistindo à veja
talvez vocês tenham com algum receio de
pensar e falar sobre o programa por ser
muito antigo mas não se preocupe o meu
também é bastante antigo vila sésamo
garibaldo é é bem nessa época agora
pense nele
imaginem esse programa agora imaginem
vocês assistindo o mesmo programa hoje
nos dias de hoje
imagine você dentro da sua sala na sua
casa assistindo esse programa
quando vocês estiverem assistindo esse
problema talvez vocês não se sintam tão
bem quanto você se sentiam a naquela
época porque talvez exista uma
dissonância do time
aquele programa que vocês assistiram lá
atrás
ele tinha um outro time porque era um
outro tempo
há aquele programa atrás não faz sentido
nos dias de hoje
ele não faz sentido porque existem hoje
uma velocidade diferente quando estava
todo mundo aqui assistindo o posto que
tomo todo mundo pelo menos eu tava
gostando alguma coisa no facebook e
recebendo informações sobre vários
eventos que estão acontecendo fora daqui
a nossa velocidade é muito maior
porém existe uma falha muito grande nós
hoje
ensinamos marketing com a mesma idéia
daquele mundo desse programa que você a
assistir a gente ensina marketing usando
os mesmos conceitos dos anos 50 60 70 80
considerados como a conhecimentos atuais
isso é muito complicado justamente para
o marketing porque marketing pela
definição como uma definição comum
entender para atender é uma a
característica que nós professores de
marketing deveríamos entender que a o
mundo mudou então eu tenho que talvez
ensinar alguma coisa diferente a fazer o
o o esse conceito de levar a gente para
o futuro com esses conceitos que a gente
tem hoje pode complicar muito a gente
pode chegar no futuro sim mas a gente
vai chegar no futuro provavelmente a pé
enquanto outros países estão mais
rápidos a existe um problema muito
grande dentro das grandes empresas e que
as empresas estão sofrendo justamente
por provavelmente por ter esse conceito
de marketing errado esse conceito de
marketing ensinado pra gente que não
vale mais para os dias de hoje o que
acontece
o mundo que a gente conhecia já acabou e
um novo mundo nasceu ea gente usa os
mesmos conceitos esses mesmos conceitos
sendo usados hoje podem levar a gente é
uma situação muito complicada no futuro
onde nós vamos seguir a reboque do
desenvolvimento mundial
a idéia é que o mundo que acabou é um
mundo que ele não acabou virando a chave
outro mundo começou ele foi morrendo
devagar em outro mundo foi nascendo
então muita gente não percebeu essa
diferença
esse nascimento a gente parte de alguns
conceitos que por exemplo a gente pode
pegar por exemplo a pirâmide de maslow
que fala que uma necessidade é mais
elaborada
só pode ser atendida depois de uma
necessidade mais básica tecido é
atendida como que a gente pode explicar
então quando na periferia a gente vê
garotos pobres usando é produtos de luxo
acessível e não são produtos piratas são
produtos originais
por que ele comprou aquele produto e ele
ainda não tem
a iaa a segurança física à segurança
há problemas como segurança a financeira
resolvidos como que ele pode ter feito
isso os esses modelos não explicam o que
pode estar acontecendo quando a gente
analisa ciclo de vida de produtos dentro
do makro ideal a gente fica pensando em
introdução em crescimento como o que a
gente pode pensar a introdução de
crescimento sendo que a vida dos
produtos a cada vez mais curta como que
a gente pode falar em sobrevivência se
ele ainda está na introdução é é preciso
colocar algumas luzes amarelas ensinar a
colocar essas luzes amarelas para os
alunos que a gente tem três poderem
fazer um desenvolvimento melhor do uso
do marketing
há uma outra é visão bastante
interessante é com relação à aos 43
quando a gente colocou o o o nossa
oferta o mercado analisada segundo os
quatro pés
ficou tudo perfeito ficou tudo claro
fica tudo simples e aí como que
funcionava há a agente esquartejou a
empresa em 4 produto preço praça e
promoção e ficou tudo mais fácil né
quando a gente colocou isso dessa forma
a gente começou a fazer uma análise
esquartejada
depois apareceram mais dois pés ea gente
foi colocando mais conhecimento em cima
disso e depois mais dois pés quando a
gente chegou nos 8 pc a gente chegou
nessa pizza essa imagem da pizza é muito
forte porque uma pizza cada um pega o
seu pedaço e toma conta dele e é isso
que acontece dentro das empresas da
gente a gente tem algumas
características de cada um é cuidar do
seu pedaço de pizza sem pensar na inter
relação que existe entre esses pedaços e
isso é bastante complicado porque há a
as pessoas são cobradas pelo seu pedaço
e não do todo então vários problemas
estão surgindo a partir daí é veja o
conceito desses é dos grandes livros de
marketing que a gente tem hoje são
conceitos de
bíblia do marketing né são bíblia do
marketing que foram criadas e as
empresas às escolas utilizam isso porque
é muito melhor
é muito mais fácil você falar sobre a
bíblia do marketing as bíblias do
marketing existem para facilitar a
escolha da escola a das escolas sobre
que material se vai é discutir em sala
de aula e o que acontece
o problema é que a gente começa a
utilizar os conceitos antigos e dá uma
renovada neles simplesmente uma
requintada os temas antigos para tentar
explicar o que está acontecendo hoje
quando a gente fala dessa ida para o
futuro a gente vai chegar no futuro mas
talvez com o veículo errado a gente
utilizando esses conceitos a gente vai
conseguir chegar lá mas talvez com
veículo errado no trilho certo mas com
veículo errado na velocidade errada e
isso pode nos causar problemas a gente
pode chegar a uma situação em que nós
não seremos um país onde a que esteja na
vanguarda é do desenvolvimento
tecnológico por exemplo do
desenvolvimento é humano
ah e pra falar disso só lembrando da das
pontocom da bolha das pontocom é do
começo do final dos anos 90 e começo dos
anos 2000 o que estava acontecendo em
várias empresas entraram na internet
receberam dinheiro dos investidores
justamente por ter a sua a
característica de novidade
só que se utilizou os mesmos conceitos
para fazer a avaliação os investidores
acharam que era só colocar dinheiro em
empresas que iriam entrar na internet
que tudo funcionaria e não funcionou
dessa forma várias empresas quebraram
mas porque algumas empresas sobreviverão
pensa no google o google nasceu em 1998
pensa no google buscando investidor como
que ele iria falar com investidor que
ele é organizar a internet
queria fazer buscas na internet através
de isso seria rentável
pensando dessa forma como ele conseguiu
um investidor
muito mais fácil na época consegui
investidor por exemplo para uma loja de
sapatos
é muito mais fácil convencer as pessoas
que eu vou montar uma loja de sapatos
pegar dinheiro com isso
como que o google conseguiu eo google
sobreviveu então várias empresas também
sobreviveram dentro desse mercado
nesse período é de crise do ano no
começo dos anos 2000 e algumas pessoas
começaram a pensar o que estava
acontecendo
então a gente vê aí eu trouxe um e se
esse trio é porque eles trouxeram
através de trabalhos independentes muito
conhecimento pra gente dos anos 2000 pra
cá mas que em várias escolas de negócios
não se toca no assunto sobre eles ainda
se fala dos autores leva e traz nenhum
problema sobre isso mas não se fala
sobre esses assuntos mais novos e o que
é é quais são esses assuntos
a gente fala de si bank ele falou sobre
o curso é o desenvolvimento de clientes
desenvolvimento de clientes
o euro que mais a respeito de
desenvolvimento é de linha startup a a
startup enxuta e o alex o inter volta
falando sobre geração de modelos de
negócios
eles foram percebendo que algumas
empresas tinham alguma coisa diferente e
sobreviveram a este mercado
e aí se conseguiu a um denominador comum
entre eles né
e começando a falando sobre o
desenvolvimento de clientes
o steve blank coloca justamente essa
visão de que primeiro eu tenho que
entender o cliente conceito central é
geral 90 building saia entenda o que o
cliente tem qual é o problema dele e
como ele você pode resolver o problema
dele é completamente diferente da visão
que a gente tem de outras empresas que a
lançar um produto a partir de uma idéia
isso faz com que a gente tenha problemas
no futuro
você pode pensar sem armas envolver o
cliente ou lançar uma idéia é a mesma
coisa não é completamente diferente de
uma idéia quando a gente se apropria das
idéias gente defende essa idéia de
qualquer forma e trata como um filho
tratando como um filho a gente protege e
ao contrário a gente tem que pegar esse
filho e colocar esse filho
mercado e se ele sobreviver melhor se
ele não sobreviver melhor também por que
não investir tanto dinheiro
então essa é uma visão que não se fala
muito em escola de negócios a depois
startup chuta a visão de que o o o cd
deve construir alguma coisa a partir de
um modelo um mínimo produto viável onde
você possa vender é esse mesmo produto
viável e ver qual a solução que ele
resolve se ele é suficiente pra resolver
um problema então esse mínimo produto
viável qual que é a a ao resultado que
eu tenho através desse mesmo produto
viável que o que eu posso fazer para
melhorar ele depois e repito esse ciclo
até desenvolver melhor o produto é muito
melhor fazer isso do que pensar
lançamento de produto com o produto
pronto um produto que não vai ser mudado
depois então essa visão é muito mais
atual do que as outras e o geração do
modelo de negócios do alex observada é
que trata de uma análise da estratégia
do dos nove blocos principais numa folha
só e na relação entre eles o modelo de
negócio que é como eu capítulo valor
cria o valor entregue o valor agora com
um conceito central de proposta de valor
é qual o problema resolvido o meu
cliente
pensando dessa forma eu vou trabalhar em
tentar entender qual é a pergunta que o
cliente faz que a única resposta é você
então pensando dessa forma é o caminho
inverso de tudo que a gente está
ensinando hoje dentro das faculdades
conceitos mais antigos e além disso até
pela recenseado o assunto
os últimos estudos que nós temos falando
sobre como nós tomamos decisões como
nosso cérebro funciona
pensando dessa forma como nosso cérebro
funciona a gente começa a perceber hoje
que muitos mitos que são ensinados ainda
em sala de aula já estão derrubados por
exemplo a quando a gente pensa no
business to business né no mercado entre
empresas que a gente fala que tudo é
muito racional não é emocional
eu não mas num outro viés por exemplo eu
não quero perder o meu emprego
eu quero mostrar que eu sou capaz é de
fazer essa empresa decolar
então existe também muito muito a
decisão emocional 80 a 90 por cento das
nossas decisões são emocionais e isso
também não é estudado nas escolas
bom como o que a gente vai usar os
conceitos antigos e explicar o sucesso
dessas empresas
a gente tem o facebook por exemplo que
não tem é que tem pouco mais de 10 anos
de um bilhão e meio de usuários
as empresas estão querendo entrar pra
saber o que as outras pessoas estão
fazendo lá dentro para buscar esse 1
bilhão e meio de pessoas 1 bilhão de
pessoas por dia entre no facebook é um
movimento assustador como que a gente
usa os 4ps para ver pra pra entender
isso como a gente fala de lançamento de
produtos
pensando nesse é em produtos como esse
e pensando no uber que é mais atual o
que está acontecendo com o com a gente
hoje pensa no úbere qual há o problema
principal é que ele está enfrentando
hoje né
é pra isso a gente tem que dar uma
olhada em como funcionam as redes porque
quando a gente fala de si esses
diagramas são há um trabalho do povo
bárbaro nos anos 60
falando sobre rende quando perguntaram
pra ele qual seria uma rede que
sobreviveria um ataque nuclear a uma
catástrofe e e é ele concluiu que uma
rede distribuída onde todo mundo como se
comunica com todo mundo a pode
sobreviver muito mais fácil que uma rede
descentralizada onde um ponto principal
concentra todas as informações ea partir
daí a gente começou a fazer uma analogia
com as redes
entre as pessoas também é justamente
dessa forma quando a gente fala que hoje
a gente vive num mundo descentralizado
não quer dizer que o descentralizados
seja melhor ou seja a
a melhor nos dias de hoje porque ainda
existe um ponto central em alguns
lugares que decidem tudo o que vai
acontecer e quando a gente olha aí para
analisá a uber o que está acontecendo
o ubs é o seguinte uber entendeu que a
gente está indo para uma rede
distribuída e se você quiser usar um
carro de alguém você usa
você escolhe uber já o que está
acontecendo com o empresas e de táxi
sindicatos é que eles se vêem ainda numa
rede de centralizada e é uma rede
descentralizada ou onde existe ainda
quem comanda alguma coisa só que os dois
mundos estão vivendo ao mesmo tempo eles
estão com existindo e álcool existe
existe o conflito então a visão dos
taxistas é essa de um mundo
descentralizado ea visão do uberaba do
mundo distribuído quando acontece esse
conflito
a aas os órgãos reguladores querem
controlar o órgão regulador é justamente
um órgão por central desse mundo
descentralizado o que faz com que o
verdão se preocupe com alguém que queira
regular pode regular quanto quiser
o mundo é distribuído não vai fazer
diferença então vejam esses conceitos
não são ensinados e marketing da maioria
das escolas
esses conceitos são deixados de lado ea
gente continua discutindo a história do
marketing que está acontecendo lá atrás
o que a gente precisa entender é o
seguinte antigamente a gente trabalhava
com um produto para atender uma
necessidade quando na verdade hoje a
gente vive dentro de uma situação em que
eu tenho uma proposta de valor pra
resolver o problema de um cliente
nós estamos ensinando as pessoas a criar
produtos pra resolver o problema do
cliente e isso nunca vai acontecer
o que a gente precisa fazer a partir de
hoje é reescrever o marketing no dia a
dia dentro das escolas
e como que a gente pode fazer isso
primeiro ensinando o aluno a conhecer o
seu cliente isso é muito mais importante
que qualquer coisa
conhecer o cliente e criar valor para
esse cliente é muito mais do que um
simples discurso é uma mudança
completa em tudo que a gente está vendo
e ainda ajustar a proposta que ele tem
nós não ensinamos os alunos ajustar essa
proposta e ensinar os alunos a criar
coisas únicas
é isso que vai fazer a diferença é isso
que vai transformar o nosso é futuro em
algo melhor do que aquilo que está
programado para acontecer ou seja chegar
a pé no futuro
era essa a mensagem principal que o
marketing do fim do dia o fim de um
mundo é que existe um conceito que é
história do marketing
existem outras coisas que estão
acontecendo agora que nós estamos a
estudar e ensinar os nossos alunos é
esse o futuro que eu vejo obrigado
pessoal